Aaahhhh….SCP-914 - The Clockworks.
One sheet of 8.5x11in printing paper with
handwritten instructions reading: "I would
like a Quarter Pounder with Cheese.
No pickles, no onions.
Large order of fries, and a medium pepsi"
was placed inside on the setting 1:1.
The output was the same sheet of paper, with
the text: "“I would like a Whopper.
No Ketchup, No Mustard.
Small order of onion rings, and a medium Coke”.
The next sheet, with the same instructions,
was placed on the "Fine" setting.
It produced a stack of US currency, printed
with pencil lead, equivalent to the cost of
the food order.
The final sheet, also bearing the same instructions,
was placed on the setting Very Fine.
It produced a sheet of paper inscribed with
unidentified symbols.
Anyone who looked at this sheet of paper reported
a sudden craving for a cheeseburger.